this vehicle is running short of urea
and so could millions of diesel cars
buses trucks and emergency vehicles
across south korea
the fuel additive is imported from china
but it's putting on the brakes
the situation is really bad i drove
about 70 kilometers to a petrol station
to just get some urea for my truck and
there were long queues of vehicles and
my turn didn't come so i just left
empty-handed
drivers are panic buying and their
reports of hoarding fuel stations are
running out of stock
eight or nine truck drivers out of ten
don't come anymore we've lost eighty to
ninety percent of our big customers
they always ask why we haven't secured
enough urea so we feel very sorry for
them
urea water solution is used to cut toxic
emissions of nitrogen oxide from diesel
vehicles
in 2015 in an effort to curb rising air
pollution the south korean government
made it mandatory for all diesel-powered
cars buses and freight trucks to use the
chemical
china is a country's biggest supplier
but since october it's faced a cold
shortage that's created its worst power
crisis in years and beijing has now
tightened exports
in south korea the president is calling
for calm
the government is doing our best to
solve urea import issues promptly and
find alternative sources so there was no
need for excessive concern
a military aircraft is being flown to
australia to get supplies
we firstly arranged to import urea from
australia and are currently in talks at
government levels
regarding this the defense minister is
also preparing support for rapid
transportation
many fear the shortage could force
millions of cargo trucks off the roads
causing major disruptions in farming
businesses industries and factories the
overall production of any kind of
material here korea is threatened to be
to be halted so this is a supply chain
crisis for home here inside korea but
also for exports and korea is such an
important exporting country in the
global scale so this could also mean
global impact asia's fourth biggest
economy has so far managed to offset
much of the economic damage from the
coronavirus pandemic to strong exports
but many here are worried if the urea
shortage continues that recovery could
get a lot tougher priyanka gupta al
jazeera